I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] my sidecar
don't say psych crunch [ __ ] right
sidebar oh man
sure birthday mr. Boober
happy birthday to you this is amazing
not eating carbs I'm 53 you bailed out
what don't hold the downside did is
there anything worse on those magic boys
thanks guys
psychically I know you come through
birthday hmm daddy cars for everything
you have to it's the one day you
actually eat cards true is it good
delicious yeah I'm still not done well
there we go it's [ __ ] rock Monday and a
couple things I want to say first of all
I want to go it's my birthday yesterday
well Shane's birthday but don't give a
[ __ ] about my 53rd let's see I thought I
[ __ ] up I posted 52 but after 50 here
did you post about my birthday I did
dude who cares
annually one who care to the 50 who
cares you're right really who cares
about birthdays after 21 well so at 53
and I get 5000 messages I have to
respond thanks that that's tyre I know
everybody's awesome and very spawning
yeah but my I have this and I want and I
think the audience is gonna identify
with this my Tesla's hurting my leg why
I have a repetitive drive it's though
now you got to keep your foot on the
fight the minute you take your foot off
the gas it stops okay it doesn't co-host
cuz there's no right yeah so I've got a
monthly I got a cot I wouldn't know I
have a chronic ache in my lower [ __ ]
leg a chronic leg and everything it's
because I keep moving my foot back
that's worth get helped add to my
planner fresh ice it did cuz I kept oh
yeah ask you've grown like this all day
it's a real thing
for me I'm actually my Tesla is becoming
undriveable for me you know you're
coming on the pair hold you they suck
one set on fire no I want to I want to
trade it in and get it no no yeah what
else you getting it I want a cape
anybody works for Tesla first of all
help me out second of all thing well but
somebody who's has this problem reach
out to me cuz I don't know what's going
on it's a third of all what car should I
get let's burn your car though first no
I'm not burning my car is it a lease
it's a lease no no cost me to hold off
the edge no DC and then Blaine oh no the
Sun it's a bummer because I love my test
of it I don't think I can physically
drive it anymore hey I know I'm actually
in pain I'm constantly rubbing my leg
and I was like take my ass smart for day
see what you think oh I'd be a fun car
for you yeah maybe right it won't be so
gay good car right yeah it's a real car
is that what you would recommend for me
I think so not a Porsche
no no Porsche you're not a Porsche guy
huh I mean I'm a Lexus guy aren't I
oh no I am an old Lexus guy no you're
not no kind of I'm kind of a slick
[ __ ]
hmm is there anything Mercedes that I
should drive
Justin good Mercedes out there really
hell yeah some AMG's and stuff a little
too fast for me because I don't care but
I like to get up I want pick up what I
like the electric cars there you get
then regular cars can you though oh yeah
there's a little lag though is never
brother no lag no yeah cuz when you push
down and even yours even your stupid
Porsche that would beat the [ __ ] out
mm-hmm yeah you don't have the hyper one
I know but if I push down and you're
there's no lag there's the daddy one off
the line I still be a little bit you
know your cars boy you know it's boy you
don't get excited to drive that thing
you drive an iPad you Joe
now I do like the truck trucks pretty
close Tesla truck I'm not getting that
books I'm not I'm not a surfer in
Manhattan Beach Johnny
yeah true did you do anything for your
bday what I do in my bday absolutely
nothing didn't grow up for like a nice
dinner
no your Rogen went out Saturday night
right yeah talk to you guys good yeah we
had a good time it's Thursday night
Thursday
who's that Thursday night when I talk to
you know
it's Friday night with the owner of
Felix it was really was that for your
birthday
no just just catch up yeah that's kind
of a celebration it was great it's nice
great Tang so that's kind of a birthday
thing I guess so what do you do at 53
like I don't really like my birthday
really feelings always get hurt yeah my
feelings got a little hurt
yeah because I'm not a planner and my ex
was out of town and then my kids didn't
really they were like whatever and it
was like it's fine it's 53 I don't give
a [ __ ] I'd rather I should have just I
would have liked to have just not told
anybody and what I didn't tell anybody
yeah it's hard I'm just kind of fly
under a fly under the radar on your
birthday now there's like Google Alerts
when everybody knows yeah like Wikipedia
business people like hey I'm a broker
right here either like young girls get
like no no what are you gonna do though
what else what do you need you know I
don't need anything new car but I'm
reminding it was getting my car I'll buy
you that and I need to buy a new car
right oh yeah your birthday was Sunday
we were like yo you posted Lana's
birthday at nine I know his birthday was
yesterday with the kobe bryant thing you
have to like a everyone stay happy
birthday to Brian Thomas a for money
yeah and I'll taste it for mine I
thought about that too cuz III had three
bombers in in my weekend this is so
[ __ ] weird so the day before my
birthday I'm sorry it was the day of my
birthday it was the day in the morning
of my birthday but mm two people I know
who are one a 64 in the other 62 I know
them well though and I've known them
many years and they both call me to tell
me that they have cancer and I'm not
kidding and one is a very rare form of K
I don't know but but one is uh no I
think you might have met one of them but
but either both have yeah and and and
they're both full of life and good
people and I went mmm I was like wow the
one they're both serious situations you
know life it's not a fight of your life
yeah kind of stuff and and it was really
sobering and then and then Kobe Bryant
dies that was a bummer I'm not a
baseball guy
I mean I've asked
but what really got me was his daughter
and then I find out a whole family and
then I find out three other little girls
and nine people and I know Evie I know
there are tragedies in the world here a
lot of tragedies in the world because
that's so close to home because it just
it just sucks it's just a bummer the
whole thing's a bummer it's just such a
bomb it was so mainly I thought about I
thought about Kobe's wife and two
daughters and he's got a third who's an
infant but the two daughters and they
have to walk by their child's room their
sister's room their child's room and
that child's never gonna be in that room
and I think about that cuz you and I
have children you and I have to an
animal we know how how unbearable that
is for them right I told chin all I
couldn't sleep last night thinking about
you know Kobe at 41 young man has no
life for any walls and you know why he
was flying a helicopter no to spend more
time with family he got a health care
because he wants in traffic so he takes
kids of school spend more time with him
sure so that's the original reason he
got the helicopter was 13 who is that
who was always like I'm represent yes
she's a Jew she had the Mamba mentality
yeah so I can I was tell chin this I'm
blows about I couldn't sleep last night
thing about just when that plane you
know there in that fog and they were
trying to figure it out and right before
it hit the thing in here pull up pull up
and I just you I didn't know that
yeah oh there's a video of this is a
pilot or there's there's there's after
the the investigation yeah so there's
deep fog and he got a special clearance
still fly so there's a deep fog and in
calabasa where Calabasas where he was
going
you know they ran into the mountain and
I just picture you know these these nine
people I you know I'm sure there was
talking like I can't see ice you know I
bet they hear Papa and they're just that
you know you know yeah you know I bet
his heart went oh [ __ ] yeah and just
that yeah ah yeah yeah and I you know
and I just think I just I don't I can't
get this picture on mine him just one oh
and then yeah yeah I like to think that
I think about and I like to think it was
quick like to think that well I'm sorry
[ __ ]
I'm shame says that I'm sure was
I just I think about the phone call that
his wife got and his wife having to tell
her kids and that's the kind of Devon
and that family there there was a family
baseball coach from Orange County with
his two daughters as an homage to was he
I'm sure phenomenal coach and it was
just such a bummer man it's one of those
heavy bombers but it's the heaviest I'm
eating I'm eating in a restaurant in the
healthiest I'm eating in a Lebanese
restaurants place called playa Peter
which is really authentic Lebanese and
the guy there who cooks all the food by
his hand he said he said his daughter
was killed to it I went oh you know cuz
I have an eleven year old I go oh no I
look up and he said my daughter's 13 and
he went back to working it was just
these heavy there's nothing to be said
we just shake our heads hold our heads
down you know in in some ways you go the
day before this you would have said the
Bryant's are the luckiest kids in the
world
that's that household and everything
allowed and then then you go there the
most unlucky and you know just shows you
how fragile life is he I'm sure you woke
up that's when I was like my toes go hi
babe I'm gonna take Gigi to basketball
and then we should be back you know
probably round 4 or 4:30 so make sure
they have these plans and then it's like
yeah it's over me yeah it's over play
that video I think each in a fume
described why he has the it's and I I'm
sure it's always been flying all over
the world
everybody's feeling but it's like you
you can you can cut the sadness with a
knife in element when you get on the
trafficking everybody is it everybody
well he was a Laker right 20 years after
school activities all that fun stuff
even though he kids but then traffic
started get really really bad right and
I was sitting in traffic I wanted to
missing like a school play no sitting in
traffic and this thing just came out and
I had to figure out a way where I could
still train and focus on the craft but
still not compromise family time so
that's when I looked into helicopters
gonna be able to get down and back in 15
minutes and that's what it started so my
routine was always the same weights
earlier morning
kids to school fly down practice like
crazy do my extra word media everything
I needed to do flat back get back in
carpool line pick the kids up and my
wife was like listen I can pick them
although my no no I I want to do that
because like you have road trips and
times you're not you don't see it is
rare you know so like every chance I get
to see them they spend time with them
even if it's 20 minutes to their car
like I one day you have to school I get
that you and I live that way I'll do
whatever I can
I raced back to take them tennis or
whatever it is there's a reason I don't
work on Sundays there's a reason why I
won't do any shows at a certain time I
hope there's a reason why I don't do
that many other podcast you know what
you've done with this I race home you
know and you know you you know and you
you're a parent and that this is all you
did describe how much you love your kids
when my kids are watching TV i watch
their faces I don't watch the TV oh yeah
yeah yeah
you watch how excited oh yeah so yeah
man we should probably address such um
we should probably address because we've
been getting a lot of dm's and stuff I
think it's appropriate to address and I
don't like doing this so I don't like
giving it any time and I don't like
given at any I don't like honoring it
with any attention but I do think it's
it's it's important to address someone
who's in our community that we know
who's been on this podcast
Ari Shaffir and what he said in his
video and his is the reason why I sent
him a text yeah I don't I don't believe
in talking behind anybody's back cuz I I
got a lot of it I got a lot of I got a
lot of text from other comics were like
can you believe this please no but are
very close to him so men and a lot of
people in the business that we're really
outraged so know when I saw it instead
of I didn't want to join the meal a I I
like to talk about if I'm gonna talk
about somebody I'm gonna talk to their
face but no one talks [ __ ] about them
everyone just goes I can't like you
can't believe it something's wrong
what's going on here and and and I said
I sent him a long text about how I just
found it really offensive and I
regretted sending the text I even said
to him I go because we got into a little
bit yeah you did and I and I and I and I
realized I said I don't know you that
well
and I'm actually regretting I even set
the text in the first place what am i
doing why am I even why
what am i scolding are you an energy why
my I can't why am i what am i doing make
that it's not my place to even say this
to re but I didn't want to talk behind
his back I want to talk to him but it is
and it isn't cuz you're cut you know
your mentor your older guy you've been
around the game longer than everybody so
it's like I I guess when I saw it just
made me sad then I like I don't I I just
I don't I don't get the humor in in any
of it I didn't like the whole the whole
shock see if Ari was if Ari was an
[ __ ] I wouldn't care and I'm gonna
say this to people that I don't know Ari
well but I know people know Ari very
well and and I'll say this about Ari and
and my experience up until now with Ari
has always been that he's actually a
very kind-hearted yeah very kind-hearted
human being who means everywhere and
everywhere all the best all he's been
nice to me that so for me I swear to God
and I think you know this is true when I
saw that and I was getting all those
texts I guess because I am older and I
shouldn't have done this
I had this instinct to be like hey bro
you can't do this yeah I think I don't
want to see him Lord his my driver and
that I hope you know I tag some was like
dude I can't believe he did this this
isn't a joke to me and yeah I'll haven't
learned that but if you are fewer Rogen
or someone yeah his peers that's fine
he's never been yeah I don't felt
inappropriate but I felt like I
literally felt like his people were like
well this is it for him this is gonna be
like you know when you do something like
this getting sponsorship getting a
special that's very big may just makes
it way harder it's already hard hell if
he cares my instinct was to be like hey
this isn't who you are at least I've
never seen that but he's done it before
and I'm like an outing well we've had we
had a discussion with someone else you
pose with him and he goes well whenever
someone dies it's what he does I just
went but why like even creatively it's
not that funny it's not I think I'm sure
there's a niche group of fans I don't
know I'm just saying that might be like
oh yeah they're like but you know you're
not gonna win doing like dude it's
here's what I here's life that yeah it's
not the way to go no it's just not it's
not cool in any fast I think I think
what we're trying certain things go
beyond what's called they state they go
beyond there's something called calm
decency and this this was against common
decency but but - it wasn't but my said
but why do it though is it to move
tickets is it to gain those bad
underbelly of rotten fans who jump on
board I don't but what but why do it for
to get attention maybe an angle maybe
why don't let me Cleo but even but even
she's but the narrative of oh I'm glad
this rapist died hold on Ari
hold on you know he's always been nice
to me nothing but great to me so I'm not
going bad on alright what I'm saying is
I don't understand it because from from
his point of view the rape stuff the
allegations look into that man he didn't
he says he followed it really closely
cuz I did it though you did but she
didn't though no but yeah I'm I'm from
there I'm from there I'm from there I
know people who are around there I know
people who know that girl I don't I
don't have all the facts I love all your
a lot of him I have he says she says
right which already does - any narrative
that I want paint I can Google on the
Internet if I want to Google Brian
counts an [ __ ] I can find a narrative
that's gonna paint that yes I find Joe
Rogan's an extreme leftist I can find
that near death somewhere on there I can
get that confirmation on the internet so
if Ari was searching for that you're
gonna find it yeah but you don't know
the facts now I don't have all the facts
what I do know is what know what the
courtroom found we know that yeah we
know it settled out of court
yeah and we know and we do know that
that young lady's history that was
proven after this and we do know account
upon account of personal people that
know Kobe Bryant says he's a great guy
we do know a guy who has access to the
women upon women that has no history of
rape before this we do know that so when
a man of this a unicorn amongst human
beings dies and he's a dad and what he
represents guys with his daughter yes
and you take the narrative to others to
go all this rapist it's just like well
hold on dude why do you think nobody
talked about that rape case also if you
cared about that rapist when you heard
about that girl did you give her money
where were you for but why now and you
can't say I looked into the case when it
was
this was not this no that's think what
happened was happen is it he had an
impulse he was easy because Hollywood
liberals who attack comedy into I
rooting for the Lakers more than they
dislike great there's a very clumsy
thing to say
it's it's it's it's very clumsy all of
us go there that's such a clumsy weird
thing to say and and I and and I I will
say this about him I was the only thing
I will say that I heard from a reliable
source is that he didn't know Kobe was
on the chopper when he wrote this with
children being I'm not kidding I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not hey bro there's
any double down well he double down been
doing well what I'm trying to say that
could you add that text exchange yes I
did and then and then what I realize
that I think it what I want to say is
this it doesn't matter what I was gonna
say it doesn't matter it's still just a
[ __ ] thing to do and and seem so out of
character for this guy
like it's so powers always been he's
always been nice to me he's always
always been great to me men are he has a
million reasons I don't know him I don't
know him well enough but he never does
yeah he's always been great I saw I went
oh because I first got brought to my
attention from Rappaport yeah
reporting goes this is your [ __ ]
friend like we're cool now if you did it
or Rogan did it or you know D'Elia did
it that's a different argument
I don't yeah I don't know are you enough
detect so now I saw and I don't either
I'm in no position to tell ru what he
can and can't do yeah you know Ari's a
grown-ass man I just found it so ill in
poor taste bro it's beyond even there's
common decency it's poor taste it easy
thing to do it's not it's like even the
whole thing's no comedy in it there's no
comma comedy but there's also no like I
looked into the rape no you did in no no
I just it's it's a it's not only it's
puzzling and if it offended me and it
actually hurt my feelings to me
I mean he said I found it I found it it
made me so angry and it's why I sent
that text I was getting all the Santa
because this is not I can't I can't have
it we can't have it my thing is is like
that's that stuff exists I expect this
out of like those trolls like online
makes the wrong dude go Celtics it's
that makes sense that make that's other
right you're looking for some sort of
attention you're not getting and you're
a loser and you're tall and you're you
have an egg is your avatar that makes
sense or you're you're a private profile
I get that from from their Seidler
they're looking some way to get
attention yeah but with Ari I'm like it
just it doesn't make sense yeah because
no one's gonna go oh dude did you see
Ari [ __ ] on Kobe Bryant the day he died
I'm buying a ticket to that show yeah I
just don't I mean if they did god damn
it man yeah in a way it's like getting
it's like probably always been nice to
me that's what but it's but the promise
I think what people are doing is with
what happens is you you you're profiting
it's profiting off of the death and
tragedy of of someone in a way it's
trying to jump on that either way I
think it sucks
it's very puzzling I don't I don't I'm
gonna end it with this I don't need to
talk about him or or to him or any of
that anymore it's all good I just want
to say that - because he do it - yeah
because we got a lot of with this let's
do it to get a rise everyone cuz because
then we're given what their dad was like
any human being if you ask somebody who
did something like this they maybe in a
year he won't he'll he might regret it
maybe he's done it before yeah I think
he's got no history I really don't he
does cuz I were type again retiring a
mutual friend he knows and very well
goes he kinda always does this I don't
agree with it but he can always doesn't
like a [ __ ] yeah I'll tell you right now
being if you did this I don't know where
your next show is it you did this yeah
seven people show up to your show yeah
yeah but I would never do that I don't
have that in my in my body to do this
yeah it's it's it's a weird it's it's a
weird it's it's more of a [ __ ] you to
the world it whatever's going on with
him it's a it seems like an anger and a
[ __ ] you to the world that's what it is
so I think as a count was a suspended no
this is from a while back so I'm just
seeing what his history
like yeah I don't know I don't know I
guess it's just puzzle it's just we had
to what we had to address it because he
knows a lot of people are hitting us up
with this I had to address it I didn't
want to I guess that I stand by
everything I've said here I'd say right
to his [ __ ] face I'll always say it I
die I'm it's disappointing it's
offensive IIIi can't have it around me
no makes me sad and I just all of this
said I have and will say to his face
that's why I'm not talking behind I'm
happy I don't like going bad on anybody
who can't defend themselves who's right
here now I think this is indefensible if
I saw my have nothing to say what are we
gonna talk about I bet as far as this
like it's like I don't agree with you
man I think it's super [ __ ] up okay
well I think you can I can make a joke
anytime nothing's too soon all right
that's your prerogative that's fine but
it's not a joke there's no job well I'm
just but all right where's the comedy
could you find any comedy I've been
doing how many a long time you would
know better than me Brian I have no idea
but that's what I'm saying there's
nothing to talk about
yeah I don't know I'm just running just
it just hurts my feelings are he's
always been so kind to me and I see I'm
like well I can't I
what are we in he did he pull it down
tweet
I heard he tried to post it on birds and
then there's a video that I think he's
got Birds and they posted a video and
then I think the backlash was so bad you
took it down but then you know how you
know Twitter or Instagram what's it's
out its out do ya alright we've said
enough that's where we stand on it and
you know I have a question about that
you guys know him kinda like you kind of
know his history right you don't don't
you got to realize like and you speak
for me cuz you're here before this but
when I got brought in to like the group
I met Brian I met Chris I met Sasso
Rogen Brian Sasso Dhulia those were my
guys I was never like oh he was already
in New York yeah I know re through Rogen
and then you know then he's friends with
Bert
everything I know about re-up and
everything I've seen with Ari
everything I've everything I've seen
every conversation I've had with him
everything I've watched him do up until
this point has been
I'll say that's what's I don't know
enough but I've he's done that's why I'm
just tell you the truth in your Lord I
don't [ __ ] him now when people he's done
shocked stuff like this before well I
don't really see I don't I don't see a
lot of stuff but this this is a this is
seems to be a necklace I'm asking do you
think it's self-sabotage yes in no not
with Ari
I think he'd I think this is this is
what he does huh
it's good I guess there's me a niche
demo who are like oh yeah dude oh yeah
you know have no [ __ ] clue what
they're talking about huh if you're well
those people do not come to my show
don't come to Brian show don't listen to
this show this ain't for you I'm not
about that man yeah yeah I won't
tolerate any of them no man it's a bit
bum me out
me too it blow me up I you know I got
global perspective I know there's
tragedy everywhere and I know there are
bigger tragedies but that bum me out
it fine it should that's crying this
morning I was crying this morning man
they're shown his daughter you know
Brennan you're an athlete and I think
you have a very intimate understanding
of what it took to become him and how
rare that dude and every to God I have
no idea I don't know well that's right
and it's more than just athleticism it's
the ability to manage excellence across
your whole life this is what we all try
to do we all try to be we all try to
self perfect and when you see somebody
who's able to do it on a level not just
athletically socially but as a family
dude and you see that you you are
reverential when I I saw him one time
never met him but I saw him I was just
and I was looking at him ago well that's
he's the best he's the best at what he
does anytime somebody like that is lost
at 41 when they have a lot more work to
do it sucks
it's a [ __ ] bummer and to be mocked
all right this is such a shame man yeah
and and and again let's not the family
the other family oh the other family
other people died there horrible the
other thing just is terrible the other
thing too is you know there's a very
famous race British racecar driver who's
like a billionaire who got around
helicopter and him and his family died
in the same way yeah in a helicopter a
few years ago my dad who's we hire let
me bring out up chin I call my dad as a
pilot and he looks at these stats off
agoura helicopters dangerous and he said
no he said people live in helicopters
they live in them you know yeah but the
thing is when you crash it's not it's
not if you're graduate more gonna yeah
that's right oh that's the guy yeah we
talked about this guy before just on it
about how he looked and then we saw this
crash - yeah so was with this daughter
yeah very famous yeah yeah Jesus adds
we're all gone yeah I think that's the
biggest thing like you know you just you
realize like [ __ ] man
you never know no you never know my 50s
was three years ago this if you like
three years ago shits moving quick dude
we're moving quit the shits moving quick
let's go because I'm gonna die and I'm
gonna die of old age
yeah all for sure you know Syria left a
hundred something hopefully y'all let me
for sure lets me so sad for you oh no
don't say that you always worry me cuz
ya know this guy I'll just have an issue
sometimes like that time you're like my
I just saw I can only see out of one eye
sometimes are you every time you just
start sweating and throw up I'd be like
hey something's wrong I'd be calling
what's going on your your casual you're
not a hyper contract you like I'll
figure it out I'm like whoa you know and
then somehow get that kidney thing going
right now stay over the old scale you
have that dormant tumor that's the
craziest one ever it's got a dormant
tumor in his he'll has brain what's
going on with the older kid the old
kidneys now is your tumor is that why
you're such a giant hug me like big
Silva do you have giantism let me do a
patio speaks ill big cell though ya know
it's like in the it's in the back in the
face doormat a lot of people have been
calling me asked me what it was like to
get manhandled by you but here's my
thing we when we rest like that my
character what the [ __ ] are we doing
people bring like dude what the [ __ ] man
people love it though they lie they like
seeing you get beat up I love sitting
since they like seeing a regular gay guy
you know I get get gorilla
they like seeing a j-man taken down by a
straight white man's right hey yeah yeah
you know my favorite people are like uh
too bad you can do that in the UFC it's
like hey [ __ ] off hey yeah he'd do it
[ __ ] teach nobody could stop your
double like actually I didn't feel bad
about not being not being able to sprawl
because I don't think he brought was a
couch to anything but we did break the
couch no one was able to stop your
double your snappy double there nope
crow cop Lavar Johnson Mitrione not even
that I priced you shot uh no Kara yeah I
just shot an Rothwell on the outside
just 104 guillotine purposes in the
future
did you add on the outside hope you're
studying tape bro I did study it because
you tap my head and you go down and I
should know better to think that's a
[ __ ] I get you thinking now that I
know it you'll now do the same I'm in
the basement yeah you'll never you'll
never make my attic you'll never fake it
my attic and hit me in the basement
again all right
I'm just saying cuz I know what's coming
now okay dude hey what are you in do for
the Super Ball
you know what's Sunday you old [ __ ] I'm
glad you asked I'm glad you asked I'll
give you three guesses or where I'm
gonna be now I could be on the field
with my friend Tariq Aziz me too so
could you have had several offers we
could both be down there actually got
offered to do some stuff for the Super
Bowl really Papi's not flying down to
Miami to do that tough tough because we
don't like to fly it's just too much at
the end of the day plus I'm in Cleveland
Thursday to Sunday
now I'm gonna live in Ohio okay you're
in Ohio I'm in hilarities you're at
funny funny bone come on I'm only there
Friday Saturday
okay are you doing Sunday showing Cleo
I'm not oh they don't fly back on the
Sunday now would you shoot down to Miami
shoot down in Miami or I could shoot
somewhere else where were two words
where would you expect me to be in I
give you three guesses um well you give
me at the podcasts on Monday I assume a
rip you obvious all that guess my dog oh
yeah are you going to San Francisco you
talk no Denver
we're think celebrity New York thinks
celebrity yeah
Sundance is in a row now you [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ] if you need me I'll be at
sliced loans house hey you all regular
geriatric [ __ ] if I have to see another
post of all you again for every occasion
I'm gonna freak out that's that's
because of me you just I guess just get
some pages no just have fun with your
friends nope flavortown to [ __ ] beat
it I was always in the shot like this no
dude get back in the kitchen hey man
he'd already cooked up by hell of a
storm we have a right to be in a picture
you son of a [ __ ] it's good time god
yes who knows they'll be there Strahan I
might be talking football I got a lot of
friends now we'll stay and work in but
yeah I hear you
he's the best oh I don't have to hear
about on Monday yeah
oh you just you read a better social
media
nobody spell your name Riley hopefully
it's not Brian Callaghan anyway every
fun though it's give me your Super Ball
oh yeah I'm excited about it
what insiders think they've managed to
get their butts what is that true yeah
by my own yes that's like don't salt in
the home case what what do you mean by
that he can do everything right and well
in other words I mean you can't force
him to pass in the pocket can't force
him to run and hit him on the outside I
love talking about your legs are uh
they're white huh pretty pale you know I
got Jesus some Sun and somehow they have
built-in sunblock the Sun come out right
right I like to mid the mid sucks the
mid socks I got there I've got a high
insertion calf not a bad cat 450 not a
bad carried kids where'd you get the new
kick that dude I walk around I I walk by
the old Nike store and start and that
guy said well these are these are our
class don't say Nike store though I mean
he does whatever because these are our
classes
but the the ad and my director on my TV
show where these and say they're the
most comfortable abuse the booty has a
nice day so I got the old come see ya
there for running which I don't do but
you know but I walk as long as the comfy
did ya old bride hit the bench and did
some other stuff and I hadn't lifted in
a while you saw her and I did that
seated squat where you sit and you push
the old weights he paid seize up yeah
well a little sort all over yeah all
over I'm sore too
yeah like the chest my tits my tits are
all sore I'm at its mcore the ass in my
legs
yeah and then I got my Tesla I got my
Tesla injury you had the Tesla foot test
I got the test but I got test foot yeah
test but I got test
I got test calf test front of my calf
and knee it's almost like shin splints
yes yes achy aches all through here
nothing to be done besides trade my car
in let's I'm tell you do is set on fire
you let me borrow the Aston Martin yeah
you bought all right when do you want it
I don't know as soon as possible
hate the store tomorrow night with me I
am at the store tomorrow night with you
you a brain no I suppose happy what's
that if you want to bring it tomorrow I
can over back okay yeah great mail that
time you went lecture car and he wrecked
it I do
hella managers so he's blind in one eye
and he goes oh because we were going out
of town and Brian get out you can take
my car i OB don't give me a car you
can't see likes like knots fine amigo
sure enough and he hit up two days later
he was ran over a guy on the motor side
you were so upset Brian found out cuz I
took a picture next his car like are you
so upset about my car he didn't know
what to say and I was like you know I
didn't give a [ __ ] about my car I don't
give a [ __ ] about my car I got a theory
about things I don't care about things
if you ruin my car what am I gonna do
insurance and I'll get a [ __ ] new I
don't care I've always been that way
though oh jeez I'm dudes you know dude
hop out in Charlotte some dude
I'm a homemade moonshine oh boy
that might be why my kidneys hurt oh I
had three sips of that
that [ __ ] was basically that might be
wondering yeah so Lina yeah my nose has
been running it might be bad cocaine so
we got to stop doing all that stuff
dude button [ __ ] moonshine yeah
what do you should get out of prison is
this hooch I think we should go down the
old psychedelic rabbit hole I'm thinking
about really getting into some acid to
get your age yeah I want to drive smart
I don't know he ain't gonna open up some
new pathways I definitely don't get me
you know I definitely don't and I'm glad
you brought it up you know I think it
happen I think you start taking
psychedelics and then you make one of
those like life coaches I want to come
to terms with my own imminent death I
haven't met father you haven't met the
[ __ ] I got it I still [ __ ] got
your an energy level man yeah daddy's
still got it daddy's figuring out how to
have energy all day [ __ ] rogue in
rogue in on his carnivore diet we go to
Felix best pasta in the world was he
farting no he's like he's like no I only
eat steak best steak that steak a stupid
stupid you oh we got to come anytime
yeah whatever I invited you that night I
invited you you said it Charlotte no if
Charlie dude I invited you the night
before for a dinner but either way it
was like I'm gonna take you there cuz
she'll you know it'll knock your dick in
the dirt the pasta if I don't have my
mom dude I'm like Rogan dude are you
doing the caramel meat I eat carbs in
the morning though so so but of course
Rogan the extremists I gotta [ __ ]
hear about the wonders of the carnivore
diet now yeah
and but what maybe you know for a while
it probably is really I don't think it's
sustainable I don't think you do it for
a year Wow I need some change Aikido for
that long but I'm but you how about how
about [ __ ] I have chills so low on
food truck diary are you over uni just
did i watch that podcast with Rogan
right now back he's now doing carnivore
like what the [ __ ] so even he ate
carnivore kind of get some yeah
everybody's doing this I guess III I
don't know I don't know have you even
seen the [ __ ] Rogan skin for say knees
gonna go with
yeah of course look Joe Rogan's has
become we were talking about the other
day
and he's he Johnny Carson but but he's
more than bigger
he's Barry's mourn that because he's
become one of the most influential
people in the world he just actually has
with his podcast he just is and what
part of it is because he's not trying to
be the guy doesn't part of us the guy
doesn't [ __ ] he doesn't heat but he
won't have certain politicians on he
won't have allies people on because he
doesn't believe them because they're
selling a narrative hey by the way did
not get in my show is to try to get on a
show yeah yeah exactly
he's not a myth take notes if you
[ __ ] walk away from an off yesterday
well here's the thing it's his show you
[ __ ] you do whatever he harassed
correct if he believes Bernie's his die
Bernice's and by the way when he says
that what he's saying is that at least
without already Hannah kind of believes
him because he met him yeah rogue is not
a socialist or a liberal in that sense
he's he's but he's a lot of different
things you can't be he's saying
something he goes I might vote for it's
an idea that he's playing around it's
fighting me how upset people I love it
per se you know I'm not a Bernie fan but
I listen tome on Rogan at least he's
consistent and tells the truth I don't
like any of these [ __ ] how
about that I don't like any of them none
of them are great yeah none of it I I
mean you basically pick him out and pick
picture poison none of them are great
he's got this little beef with Steve and
Iceman from are not gonna beef but I
guess Dean Smith I sent you bothers me
don't you know now I do cuz I followed
it Steven Smith called cowboy on my face
dude I don't I don't want to date your
birthday bro I will take that doughnut
and shove it down your stupid old
rocking face because you're not gonna
get away with the [ __ ] moves you did
you know it they were [ __ ] moves
alright cool
he'd called Joe Donald Cerrone
Donald over me I'm always running to
greatness Ronnie he called him a quitter
yeah I know
he called him a quitter though you
called Donald Cerrone I'm glad dude when
I heard that I was like you're out you
don't know you don't know anything about
MMA No
shut the [ __ ] up and and that's
sacrilege
you don't call Donald Cerrone a quitter
but and then even his rebuttal door
rogon he's off at least he can throw a
hook though dude huge [ __ ] you up
Hey look at me B I'm not being real
shitty yeah I'm saying if there's like a
celebrity I yeah hey [ __ ] you let's see
that let's see that let's see that
awesome hug its Peter both coming off
the ground looks like a dick punch and
again the left chef more makeup on
alright guys had some is that guy on the
left the Joker no look at this look at
this who's the middle
it's just weird right he's not an ass
he's never done a sport in his life he's
one of the best [ __ ] journalists in
the game he's amazing but stick to that
hey the guy left Joe new Joker huh
that's cool wow he's had some work oh
yeah just got cast as the Riddler in the
new Batman it's a guy who's trying to
keep his skin tight Brennan take it you
in tight this is the problem with with
cell there's a problem with men who get
plastic surgery in their 40s and 50s
don't do it
see yeah you know what you're not under
the head does he suck dick well you know
you're noticing there that his forehead
is too smooth and doesn't move my word
though and he should have a crazy it's
not yours and I'm looking at yours I'm
looking at his and it's like ask get
some tips from my friend woody I don't
understand what you're saying
you give all the ring what yep all the
rink does that look like the moon the
surface of the Moon I don't look like a
sharp a sharp an older man sharp a man
it's right know what hurts me as I go on
53 and people go okay Michael but you
supposed to say I have you ever asked
any girl what do you think I like it
like 40 yeah [ __ ] you man yeah yeah
I wear it well dude yeah of all the
wrinkles though I don't have you saw the
line in the middle here the line here
really look at my facebook job I know
you do it but there's so many wrinkles
do yep they're all over bro they're all
over your forehead come on bro hold on
you guys [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this guy to
my left you guys are my friends hold on
folks US forehead hold on I look at all
unblemished face
wipe your you see me for the first time
okay right see them first time focus on
the forehead go notice the big line down
the middle where you pointed out yeah
let me see my face for a second I'm
gonna take a picture I want to take a
look at what the [ __ ] is really gone
notice the wrinkles are you done with
this [ __ ] do it dude I'll have more
wrinkles when I'm your age let me feel
I can't see it sliding
Oh Bubba you don't know that I used to
have big wide eye I can see my honey
more is it now you look like the emoji
that's all yeah my god I can't permanent
Skeptical hippo I wish it's more like
Pat Sajak bring him up he got his lids
done this is what you dissin titty yeah
but this is not what you want cuz some
guys get brow lifts you can't get above
the wheel of fortune yeah yeah you can't
get a brow lift you see what's going on
with his eyes oh no can't do that
you can't do that she was happening to
he had his brows lifted and you for
whatever reason you go hmm something's
off he looks evil now he's an old man
dude how much work has [ __ ] mrs. van
get a bright eyes like that you can't
have as a man having bright eyes see how
his eyes are all bright Kenny Rogers
bring him up they all look like wax ring
up Kenny before and after Kenny Rogers
before hey so someone sent me a meme of
you because this is count after you get
his lids done and it was the Chuckie
Cheese doll well there you go see that's
the other problem
see what it looks like he's got his face
tightened and he had everything he gets
talked into having his face tightened
there you go no that's a it's tough man
look you're an old man by the time you
know man dude be an old man gives a [ __ ]
about you'll never see that with me I'll
just be an old man we'll see I don't
give me your eyes get another half an
inch lower and you gift you have visors
you have skin visor these [ __ ] AIDS
leave me you have skin visors hanging
off the lids well now it's just time to
get it cuz it's not gonna be overly yeah
you're right you don't do it when you're
just I'll get it for you for your
birthday
okay I'm saying to Tijuana every every
plastic surgeon
it's like lids are easy do it in my
office yeah until you come and then he
look [ __ ] yeah I know a girl who had
her lids done and one eye smaller than
the other she's like what the [ __ ] huh
and I didn't realize until she told you
walk and I go well they're home so it's
nice in the military
she's got snipers like I gotta get em
read I'm like alright well you know I
mean I don't miss it one maybe just get
the white ice get the one all sniper I
know what I don't know I don't know if
I'd ever do anything to my face uh you
don't need it well not yet dude you
probably I don't see you getting I don't
know you're young
we'll see where will your big man though
it doesn't matter when you're a big
giant I think you can just have a big
giant face you got thick skin I wanna be
tight now you just be a [ __ ] giant a
big giant face you're gonna have you're
gonna be a giant with a agile dude I
don't think you're gonna die young I
think you're gonna I think you'll live
till [ __ ] but I see now you live your
live a while but your give myself salt
70-72 it's gonna get tricky these do it
you always work out you've been staying
in shape and you eat well
yeah cardio is the biggest I don't think
I don't know that that's sweating right
now yeah yeah my kidneys you're 270 yeah
what ya know stuff one who knows I'm
sweating though bacon yeah big boy just
big you're a bully boy just big yeah
strength cuts through technique don't
ever tell me I don't ever want to hear
you say it cuz it and I appreciate you I
appreciate what you're doing yeah I like
that you don't like being a bully
yeah I I like that you don't that you
don't see when you walk into a room with
a lot of black belts it doesn't matter
who they are I know in your heart you go
if I had to lock this door everyone
would die but if it's like boo Shesha
no not big guys guys aren't big I'm not
talking about world-class heavyweights
yeah you have spoilers hanging off your
eyes huh yeah but I don't want to ever
hear you say about any jiu-jitsu guy
even if he's when he's 145 150 160 I
don't ever want you to say to me and I
don't want you say you say what are we
ever gonna be a gymnast I don't ever
want you to say publicly that that guy
could tap you you don't have to do it
you're trying to make yourself feel
better no he's your your what you're
riding no I'm not no no no I'm not doing
that I don't want you to say that it's
gonna I don't like [ __ ] humility you
could pull whoever it is hey please
don't bring up names find up I don't
need find any I know you know I'm not
saying that but your gorilla you're a
gorilla you're a bear to you you and any
beyond most guys get logs most guys you
yeah belt dogs to quote what Ben even
golden dogs for you even great dogs even
great dogs who are black belt dogs you
pull the head off their spine so shut
out to you yeah yeah but my technique is
deepening and I have a heart I have a
lion's heart and when you have a lion's
heart and your technique is deepening
sky's the limit
it's just that you're breaking down at
the same rate I am and I feel like we're
gonna get to a point do did your sense
they see that video it's very furious no
I haven't seen him but I train with him
tomorrow so let him know show them the
video say what can I do better here I'm
gonna say and then do that and I'll see
you on Wednesday we'll see how it goes I
have I'm gonna send him the footage I'm
gonna get I'm gonna have tricks hey I
swear I'm gonna have tricks do it and
and know this I'm gonna have tricks that
are gonna sneak up on you and you're
gonna get caught so careful okay hey
this is this is a note for your future
your kill me right now you're gonna kill
me right but but but for them my future
is looking bright careful okay okay hey
kid hey I want you be dead honest yeah
for your birthday
yeah did you sense they give you a black
belt I didn't see him I was too busy by
doing nothing it's in the mail I was too
busy he was at my drives he was gone are
you a three striped black belt no not
yet he was gone he was calm but I will
have my honorary black though I knew it
in no time because celebrity has to mean
something has to it's got to mean
something would you guys do this weekend
Kat I went back to San Jose for Chinese
new
year and I spent it with my family
there's the big deal yeah thank yous
though a lot of Chinese but the
Vietnamese people celebrate it Lunar New
Year on the same days tails a deal yeah
you just drink party get money gamble do
you celebrate Qin yeah
Korean celebrate same thing too no damn
yeah did you know the big deal no you
did there's no baby birthday let me pee
for you kind of no [ __ ] up it's hard you
guys want straight teeth you want
straight teeth all you got to do is get
braces steel braces that you have to
clean that get caught in your lips when
you get punched in the face or you run
into a tree or or four sixty five
percent less than what braces costs you
can go to candid they're clear aligners
okay and you can straighten your teeth
without people even noticing it and
here's the best part not only are they
totally invisible you don't have to set
foot in a doctor's office or a waiting
room because it's all done your your
your stuff is prescribed remotely by a
licensed orthodontist and they deliver
everything you need right to your door
they take a 3d image of your scan of
your teeth and you can do it at a can of
studio near you it's the simplest way to
get started alright and can it only
works with orthodontist never general
dentists but orthodontist there's a big
difference that means your treatment
will be designed by an expert in tooth
with 20 years of experience on average
alright
the older you get the crazier your teeth
become don't become one of those people
who can smile and have an apple thrown
at their face and it sticks have good
teeth so are you ready to call it take
the first step toward straighter teeth
for a limited time you can get started
with a $75 off by using code fighter at
Canon co.com slash fighter
that's candid co.com slash fighter use
code fighter for $75 off Canada co.com
slash fighter have some straight teeth
it makes a difference in everything how
many people have student loans okay it's
a major epidemic and a prob
this country but with earnest earnest
you can save money you can lower your
monthly payment they will refinance your
loans and it only takes two minutes to
check your rate online so everybody
needs a little financial relief it goes
a long way
student loan financing with earnest can
help you pick a monthly payment that
fits your budget so you can breathe easy
you know I don't worry about everything
you can space it out look life is very
unpredictable and that can affect your
bank account and you need to lower your
monthly expenses sometimes pay off debt
sooner earned a student loan refinancing
has a solution for you all right if
you're paying the same rate you paid
when you're graduated odds are you could
reduce your monthly payment that's a big
even if you have refinanced before with
today's low rate environment most people
can save by refinancing again earnest is
the easiest way to refinance your
student loans saving you time and money
you can check your new rate it's very
fast and easy basically if you complete
a few questions online takes about two
minutes and you'll get a personalized
read estimate all without affecting your
credit score sometimes when you check
your credit it actually affects your
score not so here start saving today
listeners of fighter and kid get $100
cash bonus when you refinance a student
loan at earnest calm / fighter that's
$100 cash bonus when you refinance a
student loan and earnest calm / fighter
terms and conditions apply all right
credits ya current events okay so a
video of Julianne Hough was making its
round around social media because she's
currently undergoing this holistic
treatment to better her body oh yeah and
there's a doctor that basically kind of
like he drags his hand around like the
back side of her body and she starts to
convulse and that she continues to
convulse even when he's not touching oh
he's good actors yes I love these this
guy's a con artist look at this con
she's a con artist yeah look at this all
[ __ ] although I would love watch
that's not bad
look at this [ __ ] magician energy
he's a magician
touch that [ __ ] dude me too bro
what's up with this me - movement what
the hell - what is she doing incredible
dancer actress she deserves a gun
awesome genius look at that genius
so it's your fault if you don't have I
think this day
look the quality lounge there's a Ponzi
scheme oh my god ah yes I'm embarrassed
for her yeah way to go girl what's her
name what's this Joker's name her name
is julianne hough she's an actress huh
she was originally on Dancing with the
Stars and then she became an actress she
had like a short singing career as well
how's that going well now she's a big
deal on dance with the Stars program
yeah she was like that girl on Starz
yeah she's hot she's professional dancer
oh I think she's hot yeah that but that
bums me out now she's a doughnut
no she's done unfortunately it can't be
a doughnut see I thought she was so hot
and then I see that my growl I got oh I
loved her she was so hot and she has to
be a dum-dum dum-dum
I can't hang out with you I can't every
my friend yeah yeah do you think they
talked backstage because she was like
listen she's a con man is it great in
city stalking block he's not even a good
con man like terrible she's she's
awesome
she was well off when she was like more
natural she was really beautiful I mean
now it's I don't know she had a really
cute like girl next door yeah yeah and
when I got dancer with a body it was I'm
standing absolutely what happened she's
she's did tell she did your that was her
before she's just cute she's okay yeah
well it's such a bummer when you meet
somebody that beautiful and there
that just they're just like she can
waltz on this dick not the brightest
bulb that's why she was a guy I would
run away from her so fast it's just that
when you have when you look like that
guys will put up with it you're just so
beautiful we're like [ __ ] nothing right
now though if I was alone with her and
she's like how much oh this new
technique on you you tell me feel MF
take him off and why I mean why bad boy
I'm gonna take these off whoo it's
stinky in here you have a shower I made
it scoffs hey caca I'm a big poop boobs
dude that's our plan asleep brother oh
you mind if I jump in the shower mo
where energy came out of my butt I
thought it's gonna come out of my jaw my
entire house smells like pure [ __ ] man
what are you thinking you just [ __ ] on
her massage table oh I've been bad
somebody needs to clean me like this no
better break out the Lysol why it's just
the worst idea mm-hmm sorry I ate clams
and pasta I got an erection all of a
sudden
open it Oh my boner sorry Oh too far now
too far yeah she's gorgeous
oh that's that stuff honey just farting
oh did it yoga class with Jimmy Burke
and the woman next to me
well poorly poorly young lady not not so
young you know a woman who has just had
some weight and she was a hippie and she
started just claim it's hard laughs like
that and and Jimmy goes Jimmy he looks
at me he goes how busy goes dude you
can't be farting like that and blaming
her do you know my brother
yeah act like it's just all good like
they're in the safe zone it's like [ __ ]
it's a hundred degrees right next to my
buddy Jimmy pro football player who are
doing yogi never done you
before he's a sick athlete legs all
Moscow good-looking and we're in we're
in Venice and this beautiful her name is
Shiva Rea she's this [ __ ] phenomenal
sheet when she was younger she was so
hot and famous yogi she's teaching the
class and it's all these like like you
know it'll be oh yeah she leans over and
she's got a crazy ass right crazy ass
but she was younger [ __ ] she was just so
hot like look there she's doing
something like that and Jimmy goes like
this to me goes didn't mean to do it so
like he goes
he goes yes look at her oh no and then
she rang a bell got to chill one of
years ago she would break your back she
was so hot yeah oh yeah still as hot
Shiva Rea she predicts millions of
dollars still oh yeah hi Andrew hi and
demand
there's her ass ooh she up yeah cheeked
UPS cheeked up and you know I'm not Yoda
but don't care but don't care I love you
like I'm young I eat well and I do yoga
I feel amazing
you're 28 shut up you could do anything
I mean hanging out arcade all your life
and you you could drink and you blow all
that yeah feel great in the morning
after then after your first coffee and
then it starts catch up dude
what else get Jen there you go so we
talked about this a while ago
and it turns out that the feds found a
text message between jeff bezos 'as
current girlfriend and her brother
apparently she had nude photos of him
that he said to her she then sent it to
her brother and he's the one who sold it
to a tabloid for millions of dollars i
would she said oh your brother okay dude
just heard she had a tip on it yeah
she's had her face pulled up a little
bit and that's why i don't care about
okay sure yeah he's wearing an
interesting kimono he's a billionaire
doing what the [ __ ] happening yeah
it's a turkey gobbler neck too but maybe
she entered her brother bragging I'm
telling you I'm [ __ ] Chris Barbados
from Jeff Bezos that's her story right
now she's saying that she said to prove
it
just to kind of like show I'm actually
with Jeff Bezos
people are saying that it's probably her
way of trying to get money out of him
what a piece of [ __ ] do we do we have
the pictures No
and I think he from what I read he
actually bought it off of them no now no
one has it that makes sense
oh it's a dick pic yeah it's a dick pic
here's how much do you want for him 10
million you know what let me try to have
a very gigantic hog yeah because I bet
Elon must like go ahead [ __ ] let him
loose yeah you got a couple shots in my
piece blast it everywhere yeah I'm
saying that that makes her bed like he's
probably like a [ __ ] you really don't
know and yeah [ __ ] dude hey Jeff you
can't take naked selfies oh hey Jeff but
just be single and [ __ ] tens all over
the world dude ship him to you ship the
high tens did you ever been that guy put
him in a box
ship him to never been that guy and
firstly probably feels like wow they
like me just for my money yeah she digs
him cuz he's busting nuts don't care
what what you see you you you've gone
home to a woman who you believe really
likes you
D and this man she's only speaks to your
brother yeah that's problem that's a
problem that happened she seldom take
pics we know she sent them to her
brother and then he went and sold them
to tabloid what a piece of [ __ ] trying
to help her brother up not a dumper yeah
I'd have to donate her she's got some
well but she's a tomcat in the fact 100%
Tomcat her face might fall off whatever
yeah see you again you don't need to
tighten that up that much but you HOT
older lady going so is she's a
newscaster home is she still roam off a
bumper dude hey take it easy brothers
Jeff Fez was this girl you got to be
more and she's got kids
oh my pack isn't come late no she's a
good-looking one is look at Jeff with a
TRT yeah oh yeah just a light empty now
she's an attractive older lady man I
agree
well she's not she's not always she was
Tony Robbins younger than me go over
chin to the left there
scroll up says just right there no this
one yes no that's someone else it looks
kind of like him though no that's the
agent that's
agent I got in trouble for grabbing he's
apparently an amazing guy - dude she's
super hot man boy Jeff besos really
upgrade let's just be honest there
well his wife is I guess smart no joke
chick they started together yeah I start
to gather she ransom she's the most
she's rich woman the world now that you
get the divorce yeah good for her good
for her right she you know it's like you
weren't in the gym while shooting threes
all good man Hey look she did help I'm
like yeah she's hot she is smoked ashes
dude she doesn't do it listen you don't
[ __ ] billionaires not be smoke direct
and smart I guarantee she's smart again
well we'll see we'll see dude let's go
ahead and go ahead and show me um let me
get a sense of what how old she is I'm
gonna say she's probably 47 right there
50 okay 50 not be tell me if you have a
probably cuz I don't I don't have his
pocket you'll probably lazy is I gonna
distract your Betsy that I don't think
that's true I promise you it's true
Bubba okay
Jim go back go back I have fan one
scroll down where we're all the pictures
that I'll show you one go to image or
images
I'm just saying could you deal with it
cuz I can that doesn't bother me dude so
much higher what you got on that one
it's a little off they like kind of Tom
up the [ __ ] guy dude
you know exact what I'm talking about
it's kind of sexy to me crazy I like her
either way she's my girlfriend any kind
of sexy though yeah just Bezos yeah
Jeff's got sniper I'd a sniper she
leaned I she's sexy and I think it's my
girl so I'm gonna ask you to stop
talking about her in general I like it
anyway talking about her could you deal
with them yeah I deal with [ __ ] guy you
know you kiddo
I don't mind it man I don't think that's
a [ __ ] I go to another picture chin I
promise you she's known for a [ __ ] guy I
mean even worse nowadays there's no way
there's something there
she just got cat eyes so they tend to
look know if you type in taught by
whatever her name is
it's her thing dude she's like proud
about it
no [ __ ] guy in a picture of trembles she
is super sexy beautiful yeah super sexy
beautiful
bravo Bravo Jeffrey don't crazy eyes
dude I get crazy eyes I found that
don'tdon't Oh crazy I feel it I feel
well that's yet tense okay so yesterday
was the Grammys and Billy Eilish made
history by being the youngest person to
win the four biggest awards that night
so she won Best New Artist
she got a song of record of the year
song of the year and then and rightfully
so I thought some of the year and then
Best Pop Vocal can I tell what but the
Grammys were awful man I thought they're
so bad Alicia Keys was the highlight but
the performances were dancing what in
the lingerie there's no only time but
you talking about the guy in the pink
yeah in the bustier no in all with
Ariana Grande yeah
my son cuz I go that's a guy there my
son goes I son he's he goes where it's
all girls
I got notice my homeboys notice not it's
girls I got ya just gotta give it up to
now you focus long enough but he was but
he was trying to get into the mix way
too much I would create or one rap of
the year huh yeah that's really big this
mean ended up saying that he felt like
it was a backhanded compliment just take
your [ __ ] award dude wow these people
who think like these people think
everything's against the he's one of
those people
everyone's get some I never fit in she
want to [ __ ] Grammy what about Billy
Irish I'm gonna have to get to know
where now they album of the years no
Johnny team careful old man no 18:02 no
God discovered when she was 13 on club
yeah on Soundcloud sure and her brother
write and produce all of their music I
don't like a small like bedroom and uh
where they lived I think in Echo Park or
something wow she's pretty sure yeah
she's your silver
I like her 892 I like her and I also
like depressed people yeah
but the hold the brush things kind of
get my nerves yeah and then demi lovato
yeah she's back she was crack she's
trying she's singing how depressed she
is I'm song that she wrote right before
she went away to rehab after her last
relapse that nobody hears her can I see
we can't play though because we just
hear it you can play it for him oh she's
talked about no wait no I'm not that was
her but she can sing she can sing she
can see me risings urban MMA fan she
wrote this alerted three days later she
od'd let me do this one that video sucks
she crying there yeah she just crying
right mm-hmm Wow she's had a tough time
the toughest time dude I never seen me
do that in the Grammys well having a
start again she eats a [ __ ] hug
someone give her a [ __ ] hug
hey dude shut the [ __ ] up Brian really
anything yeah that's the best instrument
Oliver you know I would learn how to
play the piano hey I took it for you hey
girl look at me I know you too right
[ __ ] no but here's the thing no it's
never too late dude you're only 53 years
young you think so listen to Gary Vee
start living I'm faded I'm afraid you
know what you need to do yeah you don't
you need to do anyway
you're 53 take from garyvee start living
the truth as a gay man and play the
piano have been liberated get ready for
me at the Grammys
here's the thing bro get metal braces
search sucking dick and playing the
piano braces I'm not getting rid of that
Tesla anyway I can't wait to be someone
different or really myself I'm gay come
wrestle me and hold me down I'll
struggle hard struggle ha have to give
myself away to you a bad dude HEC
students wrote that start living your
life I'm gay
[ __ ] guy [ __ ] gay which means I'm on
the back on you which means you're under
me Oh [ __ ] Sam in my own 53 year old
dong oh shut the [ __ ] up branded and put
my dirty underwear in your mouth
oh wow what my just ruin it ruin it did
you had me why I tell people not to
listen in the pocket archiving your
truth citizen adolescence sucking dick
[ __ ] man
get a Subaru give me the next [ __ ]
give me the next current event she needs
a [ __ ] hug I want to reach out my hey
do you need a hug can I take you for
coffee her hug she love you
I know I know she'd love him and when
I'm a kid dude coffee
he's got coffee and a hug get me coffee
and a hug she might have the best
fire-type ya bin yah yah yah yah yah yah
now your are yard art I love her talent
make it make a call right now
she and the best voices ever who Android
a the two of them have probably the best
voice I've ever heard ariana grande also
has amazing voice not not that kind of
power though right nothing has power
your honor get his palette maybe not
that range
yeah she's exact and good but not
desperate they sing in different styles
but no matter Grande's like she could
sing she used to do like Broadway she's
really good I love she's really good at
was point everyone's absolutely yeah
everyone's freaking good now yeah Jaime
Lovato my daughter my daughter obsessed
with pitch perfect so I want to get her
to me go home skylar astin yeah no oh
you're Brian's daughter yeah I moved
came out come on sing we call him the
voice no she's on the voice and he's a
very close friend of mine not Brian hey
I went and I'll see if I can connect you
I was also gonna pitch perfect 2 and
trailers not watched all three click she
wants all three yeah I told you I
watched her sing all daddy was right
though he's crying
alright let's go to the next [ __ ]
alright this is just some shots from
China right now
yeah it's not that new but these are
some shots that are freaking people out
is just people collapsing oh we talked
about World War Z
coronaviruses World War Z in China it's
like just a bunch of rats this guy
actually has his head on the ground with
blood coming out of it oh I just
collapsed Locke all right but he gets
blood yeah is that that and then what
makes it worse is all these guys with
hazmat suits on he looks like doesn't
have a head you have to that's scary man
there's that
like six case in the state's the huh not
good this guy no thing everybody's
rushing to help I know you won't be
turning a zombie though you know it's
just if you guys watch zombie movies it
really looks like the dude yeah it's
World War Z you're looking at Brad Pitt
look at my hair not your stupid here I'm
here to save the 11 million people have
been locked down that's so crazy
hey don't live in the state they're
already here yeah there's like two cases
here right yeah what mice in Orange
County one case here in LA like six
cases here in China it's kind of a
problem
sanim don't let him in might want to not
eat back to crime
bats and snakes dude is that a bat in
the hot yes is that a badger hot about
not telling you eat oh he looks happy
wait somebody's eating [ __ ] batty
from Fern Gully try it try it
fruit bat and that's very much does he
taste like fruit though your thought
about it I it's not a bat I wanna taste
like watermelon a live on fruit yeah you
really wonder they're gonna be juicy
you're eating you're eating the rock we
know so hey they're all hey let me ask
Jenna yeah solutely
and you wonder why you have all these
[ __ ] diseases involved with food
you're eating fatty and trying to China
because they they so many people on you
they were always starving yeah or you
have to UK we don't have to kill that
fruit pack now this week the beaks of
the duck hit plagues it's very short I
went to Beijing I had that best duck
around really that's all because they're
not eating that bat that's just for the
video no I feel like they're probably
eating the best wheat I think that might
be a that might be [ __ ] but that bad
is [ __ ] that's got fur on it so if
you're gonna eat that I think they want
it for the broth you know so it's like
sitting in there for a while so his anus
is sitting in the [ __ ] broth that's
great I think yeah does look pretty
happy today I don't know if he's alive
or not yeah well yeah what else you got
for me I'm not touching that [ __ ] this
is pretty crazy so they found a 33
thousand year old Egyptian mummy and
what they did was they looked at its
vocal core
it's right through the computers and
they try to reprint that vocal cords and
guess it's a sound this is the sound
that it made me yes they're the same guy
who made that [ __ ] Huff girl [ __ ] our
pants they say it sounds like this -
it's not buying this after all this work
this is the sound that they came up and
we sound like that three billion dollars
hey we've got it right all these years
mommy's strong bingo hae-jin took on
that baby this is baby discovered ac/dc
I need a little light guess all right
let's see it
this time this first time he's heard
ac/dc
I have no idea you're coming from a year
making baby noises pirate sings
thunderstruck oh he just a lot of times
it's hilarious my better shooters [ __ ]
he sneeze this is super cute execute a
[ __ ] did you see my [ __ ] funny right
now no dude it's ridiculous how cute
he's getting the [ __ ] rules let me
see him Oh another one are you guys good
give me one more man anything and the
other all right this is a nursing rabbit
this big Oh check this thing out it's a
desert hair is it a desert hair yeah it
looks just like a regular bunny rabbit
just a giant it's a Nova Scotia
something or other oh my god that kid
looks so much like me it's weird
he's many wrinkles gotta be something -
yeah it's a giant bunny Kirstie Alley's
have money that big yeah
kill it now they're really sweet I like
tears man I like their noses your felt
of rabbits nose goes a million miles and
I think
a desert hair I think it might be but
either way it's uh it's cool there was a
violent it's a boring animal though I
use that one of the pet that [ __ ] if
yeah there's but its violence he used to
uh he'd play his violin and the piano is
bunny would sit there and listen to him
so funny oh he's a real member of yeah
yeah man keep that bunny away from dogs
don't kill him this one was crazy
have you guys seen this oh yes so okay
you guys talk all the time on podcast
and every now and then you're gonna
fumble words right but this was a really
bad one I don't know check it out people
unfortunately stuttered it's a she
that's a shoot listen to this listen to
this oh he's about Kobe - yeah hold on
let me get the volume up I hate you mind
I hate this time I created this is alive
man tired huh I don't know if they're
gonna fire buddy stuttered the n-word
listen to this perfectly cast on the Los
Angeles [ __ ] Los Angeles perfectly
cast on the Los Angeles [ __ ] cos
Angeles like Escondido halt creep and
she's saying that the reason why it
sounds like that is cuz she got the
Nuggets and the Lakers boots and
combined it but he could sound like that
Grand Wizard hat on ur face hey you play
for me one more time black at least
she's as white as it comes he's a snow
bunny perfect Los Angeles disaster bed
that's what she says he looked upon
attract music Kobe Bryant Irish
unfortunately stuttered on air combined
the know that it's not like yours to say
nature's no PSA makers you you drove it
home with a hard what that happens right
that's a no
not in whatever sometimes you get hit
with a stray bullet disaster as you say
that disaster a lot of disasters and
that's one of them yeah that's it makers
makers and maybe those soap makes in May
yeah well alright that's it
Cleveland I'll see you this weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday come come get
some hilarities then I got West Palm
Beach Valentine's Day Friday for the
14th 15th
Saturday and 16th on Sunday I'm doing a
Sunday show and ok Valentine's Day yeah
alright man I'm in Columbus Ohio funny
bone Friday and Saturday only two shows
Friday to show Saturday those tickets
are almost sold out next week San
Antonio stamp my favorite Hotel forget
the name of it price yes say it so I
don't get murdered
San Antonio favorite six through the
eighth next week and after that for
Valentine's Day week I'm in Ontario
California Ontario improv and I think
that that's up Thursday Friday Saturday
the thing about adding a Sunday show I
don't know we'll figure out Vancouver
February 21st that is at the vogue
Theater for Just for Laughs comedy tour
festival then I close out in Tacoma dumb
in theaters in March Chicago Atlanta New
Orleans Toronto Minneapolis get your
tickets tief at kake.com but this
weekend Ohio yup
yeah mm-hmm I'm gonna slap your [ __ ]
face too man but you know I want to give
you for your birthday what a slap slap
try because I'll keep my hands up no way
oh you know what I'll do for your
birthday I'll give you a Botox you want
Joe sick of looking at you want no part
sick of looking at a map on your
forehead you want my head never stop
sick you're looking at the wrinkle map
on your phone call me they call me the
Cobra the man nope
they call you the head never say call
you a maple leaf cuz your forehead looks
like a leaf dude I'm a man cover up your
may believe my head keeps moving you see
all you catches there happy birthday
boomer thanks this fine kid we're out